filas cada vez más largas alrededor de
la catedral de San Giles para que las
personas puedan ingresar allí y dar este
último adiós a la Reina Isabel En
realidad tener esos momentos de
recogimiento su momento breve pero
muchos continúan haciendo esta fila es
importante para ellos poder tener ese
momento de despedirse de presentar sus
respetos a esta reina que fue la suya
durante 70 años que fue como su mamá
como su abuela ahora de la féretro de la
Reina Isabel abandonará estas tierras
escocesas que tanto amo en la tarde de
este lunes para ser transportado a
Londres viajará a bordo de un avión de
los royaler será un c-17 Glock Masters
es un avión que sirvió el año pasado en
la evacuación de kabul Y a lo largo de
este año 2022 ha servido para
transportar ayuda humanitaria y armas
también a Ucrania a bordo de ese avión
irá también la princesa Ana y ella será
recibida en Londres en la base aérea de
Jesús en el oeste de
una pequeña ceremonia en honor de la
reina y luego el otro será transportado
a buckingham Palace